democrats obsess over counterproductive
health guidance they also continue to
ignore
the public safety crisis in our major
cities if democrats really cared about
preserving life
then why are they so indifferent and
seemingly apathetic
toward the lives being lost to senseless
violence all across the country
why do they want to dismantle the police
and why do they refuse to admit their
culpability in creating this crime
crisis
here for reaction california
gubernatorial candidate larry elder and
fox news contributor
joey jones uh larry let's start with you
look you're running for the governor of
california you're doing quite well as
best i can tell
but one of the big issues i think from
everywhere
up and down the state of california i
was born there i lived northern
california southern california
it does not feel safe there right how do
you address that
and how are you going to be different
than what the democrats have offered for
literally decades
well jason if i'm lucky enough to be
elected governor of california and if
enough people go to
elder.com that's going to happen the
number one job of government is protect
people in property and it's not
happening
uh under this governor uh during the
kovid
situation twenty thousand convicted
felons have been released
uh what could possibly go wrong many of
them are going to reoffend based upon
the statistics
we've had this anti-a police narrative
that has caused
defunding the police as you know former
senator barbara boxer just got mugged
the other day in oakland
and the oakland pd happens to be black
the other day gave a press conference
where he talked about
millions of dollars being diverted from
the oakland pd
uh out here in los angeles the lapd has
lost 150 million dollars because of the
defund the police movement
it's absolutely insane and the people
who are hurt disproportionately are the
very people that the left claims they
care about
black and brown people if i become
governor i'm going to make sure the
number one responsibility to protect
people in property
is going to be enforced joey you
fought and bled for this country your
patriotism
shall never more ever be questioned and
yet
we just heard the attorney general of
texas talking about how
it's so much easier to be here illegally
to cross the border you don't have to do
things that are americans are asked
how does that make you feel right yes
you know it's sickening and what really
bothers me if i go to fly on a plane i
always quit that
if you want to be treated like a
terrorist lose your legs uh fighting
them because then tsa will treat you
like a terrorist
you know what that's okay i don't make a
stink with those officers they're
usually super nice about it
but that's the standard that i have to
meet as someone who went to war for this
country
and unfortunately lost my legs i have to
meet a higher standard than the person
in my left and right
just to fly on a plane and so i can live
in a world where
certain things are expected of the rural
followers but if you're not a rural
follower
those things aren't expected from you
it's like when a cop pulls over
the nicer car because he feels like that
person will pay the ticket it's that
kind of thing
that's the world we're living in now
democrats have purposefully made it
easier
for people to not follow the rules and
when you call them on it they say oh
those people are socioeconomically
disadvantaged and it's not fair to
expect them to do something like
not commit murder or not commit larceny
or not steal because they
they're coming from a bad place in life
and we owe them something
listen i'm all about lifting everyone up
but you don't lift people up
by telling them they're not going to be
held responsible for their actions
listen i live in georgia the community
of buckhead is trying to become the city
of buckhead
because they don't feel safe with
atlanta pd being the only way to protect
themselves
that's a big problem and it's not
something that's just specific to
georgia
and so now we're further dividing
ourselves even in our urban areas
because people want to be safe and if
their city won't keep them safe they're
going to keep themselves safe
it's just it's not the america we want
it's not the america anybody wants yes
larry we've been watching videos of
people streaming out of
their walgreens or target stuff like
that they just brazenly go in grab
stuff and go out there's no consequence
and they know there's going to be no
consequence they don't even run anymore
they just open up the door of
the vehicle and stroll away
yeah surprise surprise when you make it
easier for criminals to be
to not get caught to not be convicted to
not be incarcerated
crime goes up and regarding the uh the
order made by the texas governor he's
going to be called racist
uh but never mind the the generations of
hispanics that live in texas
generations of hispanics that live in
california for years and years and years
they don't want illegal immigration
either
one dirty little secret is cesar chavez
a hero of the united uh farm workers
he hated illegal immigration he was born
in america and he knew that illegal
immigrants
opposed threats to jobs and put down
wages on the wages
of people who are in the country
illegally so it's not a good deal for
anybody
for us to have open borders particularly
when so many of these illegal aliens
i have covet it's absolutely outrageous
no it's a i think people are losing
faith in their government
and the the equal application of justice
joey i've got just a few seconds what
are your comments on that
yeah i come from a town that's 78
hispanic inside the city limits and let
me tell you
people that live in that town came here
a lot of them illegally a lot of them
are first generation or daca
and this is the thing that people won't
tell you democrats will tell you living
in the shadows is not joining the
american way of life
every person that crosses illegally
lives in the shadows they don't get to
be a part of this great country
have legal immigration and bring as many
people as our country can take
and make them a part of our country
don't make them live in the shadows and
that's the game the democrats are
playing and it's unfair to those people
gentlemen thank you for joining us
tonight joey jones and larry eldridge
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else